Joy's on line three dory  hi are you ready for tonight Dory thinks  she's your girlfriend you have to start  thinking like a big boy let's go way up  north just you and me now wish I could  but I can't please come on it'll be fun  it's in the middle of nowhere  [Music]  if you can make it for all the holidays  with someone you found your main survive  a New Year's Eve then that says it all  what are your intentions  Daria what's the deal with the kids what  I was thinking was that it'd be nice for  you to meet the family I didn't even  know you had a family till 10 minutes  ago  woman tells me she loves you and it's no  big deal this chick is out of her gourd  we should have said it was such an idiot  I'm good back to sleep when are you  gonna start owning up to your mistakes  [Music]  just like that southern man sir not  together  [Music]  so you're okay that I love you  you